Oh
mon nom est ajatashatru la wash potato
et ce sont la chance de Dieu mec
je suis tombé amoureux du projet c'est l'
histoire d'un jeune indien qui vient d'une
très très petite région de mumbay il
ne connaît rien d'autre que son quartier non nous
développons  le scénario développant les concepts
que nous sommes dans le roman à succès
[Music]
travailler avec Dino et tous les autres
acteurs de tant de cultures différentes
a vraiment inspiré Simon virus oui
nous avons tourné dans de nombreux pays différents, il
était très important pour nous de
profiter de ces différents décors
Inde Italie France Angleterre Libye est
n'importe qui ici d'Espagne nous voulions que ces
différents pays impactent le
parcours du personnage principal
pourquoi es-tu à moitié nu dans ma malle je
n'avais pas réalisé sûr d'écrire très
simplement quoi  J'essaie de tirer le meilleur
parti de chaque acteur pour obtenir le bon
équilibre entre drame et comédie. Quelque chose dans
cette histoire fait que le film ressemble
beaucoup à une faveur, mais le plus
important, nous voulons que ce soit le cas.  e chiffre pour être
très divertissant une véritable aventure
polaire immigrants illégaux et vous n'êtes pas
je suis un touriste
touristes voyageant dans l'armoire
vous